in Japan restaurants and to be clear I
mean a ton of restaurants use plastic
food displays to entice customers and in
gujo province there's a small factory
that's responsible for more than half of
all the plastic sushi crab omelettes
duck ramen beef oh my god
that's all plastic this is satellite
Kabuki yahshua say zopo Kanye West I do
a coconut Kojo John Davis this Factory
has about 30 full-time artists because
all these plastic foods are made by hand
[ __ ] esto no dos mo vamos a tiki
pneumonia not easy mama Tsunade happily
Tezuka Rito yuca so emo no no ha ah di
una de mas uno de Aparri [ __ ] a diva muy
taco America's vote a chignon Amaya
ishigami Takahiro this Takahiro is an
artist here Nancy uh no authority no
Sanju en una hata title anonymous aporia
no sono Moneo 10 a no-show Quintin on
non-monetary Misano dare Navin n more
economical re mistake sorry God to you
Eman aoyama-kun Katamari a she beautiful
not very much this trend of plastic food
in Japan has been around since the 1930s
but blew up in the 50s and it is
everywhere
however this food it doesn't come cheap
chisaem Onoda star amazon very angry
disc adobo Okemo no OT ba a cannon toka
Okemo nanaki alto a hawaiian
gym int you need enough it's madness it
takes years of training to master this
art sight a demonise on a no es ago a
night o mo not screen i
motorist quick example a bowl of ramen
might take three hours to make while a
fish many many more
Oh da ba dee dee Moore tornado desu kedo
Anna Cellino sue cricketer Turkish
Oviedo Mon Ami team esto que co-op I
know who needs good terregino Couture
see you know to talk online a snow day a
body so even on Emilio cou this net you
can e homa knowledge cascade kappa yoko
today you know local community